Mì vậy thống bây, chính quyền của quay nâ chính thức lúc vào giải tròn cải tổ sau giọc khi bà Yuria Series
đang gồm được hội phai tròn giữ trước thủ tổ mởi ngày sau khi nhọc trước, bà trên bố sẽ tin hành kiểm
gióan toàn dễn chi tiêu ngã sát nhả nước để hôm tế mục tiêu tế kiểm thức chất, lông thời thúc
lại quá chính từ nhân hoa, khi một lớn nhằm khơi thông tiệm năng tịch để gùa ra. Bà Series
đang gồm sinh năm 18m là nhà kinh tế từng giữ trước phố thủ tổ nếu kiểm bố trưởng tế trong
thông nghiệm đầu tiên trên nền tạng só hữu íc, bà khẳng định gặp ưu tiên hàng đầu của chỉ phủ mởi sẽ là đảm bảo chuyện của
mũi chủ côn đối và tăng tốc sản xuất của khi nụ điện, nhằm hỗ trợ mà chật khẳng trên trường
á, biếp mùi nhầm tân thủ tưởng năm trong lợt cải tổ nội các quy mùi lớn gió tổng thống
vô lối đi mê dế la khi khởi sướng, theo đề xuất đã được công bủ ngày 1 xo thống bây, ông
này, nhé, tổn thống đường mạnh nhận sẽ đảm giận trước bộ trưởng của phòng trong khi có vị trình
nội các khác dự kiện sức được của hội thông qua trong ngày tới, sauong bởi các cánh trường nước,
húc quay nà cục đăng nữ lực hành gặp quan hệ về Mỹ sau dài đoạn tăng thẳng đúng năm.
Tổn thống Xe Leceki ngày bị vải thống bây thông bảo, bộ nhẹ bà Unha Stefaniecinà,
phó thủ đường làm đại xử mới tại Mỹ, vị trí mà trước đó có thúc tiên sẽ dành trường rút tệ 1 meroc,
bộ trưởng của phòng mạnh nhận, ông này hiện đạo đối mặt với các cá vụ lạng giúp quay lực.